Opla premier screamer
Bienvenue dans ce troisième épisode de notre let's play sur Outlast 2
C'est parti
Alors là, mec, je croyais qu'on venait de faire des courses poursuites de ouf
C'était heu... heu... horrifique voilà heu...
Comme tout ce qui se passe dans ce puta*n de jeu
On va sortir la caméra hein
On va pas se mentir
*bruit de pas*
Je crois qu'on tombait dans un endroit genre
bah voilà c'est exactement cet endroit
Ah, vous voyez, voila, là on est en train de faire une image d'archive
[Je suppose que c'est ici que la magie opère]
[Des chaises pour un public]
[Je l'ai seulement vu par la suite]
[Je n'aurai pas pu]
Ah puta*n il en dit tellement peu c'est horrible
Bon nous ça nous dit pas où il faut qu'on aille
Ah faut qu'on pousse ça ok
Meuf je t'aurai bien emmenée mais tu es attachée je suis désolé
Et j'avoue je suis un peu égoïste j'ai pensé à ma peau un peu
Hein, on va pas se mentir
On va passer par là
Nous on a... on a une...
[C'est quoi ses conneries ?]
Notre femme à sauver
Oh c'est une fosse
Où ils jettent les cadavres, c'est une fosse, puta*n
J'avais peur qu'il y ait un mec qui arrive par derrière tu sais
J'étais pas bien
[Ah merde...]
Haannnn ... Nan mais mec si tu tombes là t'es dans le mal
On va tomber... mais c'est évident
c'est toujours ça à Outlast
On va tomber...
Il y a un mec qui va arriver de là-bas je le sens je sais pas pourquoi
Ça faut filmer ou pas non c'est bon ?
Non, il a pas... il a rien à commenter
Roh puta***n
Terrible, c'est terrible mon gars
ça fout la frousse
Et ce petit son de violon là qui me tend
Alors je vais plus utiliser la caméra parce que ça me permet de mieux voir
en plus sur les vidéos
J'ai vraiment lu tout vos commentaires alors je vais vraiment essayer de faire du mieux que je peux
Alors, nouvelle maison
Alright
On va monter
Personne ?
A priori il n'y a personne
A priori il y a personne...
Bah...
Ohhhh... [Il est dans la maison]
Oh nooooon
Oh pitié
Oh non...
Oh non, faut que je monte, faut que je monte
Oh pitié
Oh ça commence d'entrée de jeu, quoi [Il est à l'étage]
Il a lâcher un gros : il est dans la maison
Il a lâcher un gros : il est a l'étage
Sans parler de tout ce qui est produit laitier bien sûr
C'est drôle ça !
Ok, du coup on descend
Ahh
Ok... faut s'en aller par là, je suppose
Ah ça c'est tellement le stress ces courses-poursuites là
[Je l'ai, par ici] Puta*n rien du tout mon pote !
Ok, on va aller tout droit
À gauche
Puta*n en plus maintenant ils peuvent te suivrent alors que tu rampes
C'est terrible mon gars
ça met une pression supplémentaire
laisse moi... laisse moi...
oh puta*n... nan c'est une blague
aaahh laisser moi
par là par là par là par là par là
suite
faut que j'aille par où
là haut
[ce fils de p*te, il est où ?]
Oh merde
Vas-y, vite, casse le sol, casse le sol
Casse le sol !
Yes !!
Faut que j'y aille, c'est par où ?!
Vas-y fonce, fonce, fonce, fonce
Je rampe
*coups de hache*
Ok on a réussi
On a réussi, on s'est échappé
Tout va bien
Y'aura personne dans cette maison
Parce qu'on a beaucoup de chance
Hein, dans notre malheur
On a la chance dans notre malheur, mec
On a tellement de malchance entre notre femme
Qui-
Qui s'est faite kidnapper et...
et mise enceinte euh...
Je sais pas trop de quelle manière
Mettre enceinte, pardon
J'arrive plus à parler
Put*in
Alors,
On va où ?
Ahhh
C'est pas beau du tout c'qui se passe
Ok
Y'a des reflets
Ah, un mec !
Est-ce que ça fait une image d'archive ?
Lui
Lui il est pas mort, lui
Si, il respire pas
Il est mort
Il est totalement mort !
Ce qui nous met pas forcément en confiance, hein
On va pas se...
Se mentir
On va ouvrir cette porte
Raaaahhh
C'est terrible
Oh...
Oh !
Ça fait penser au cauchemar que j'avais !
Avec la classe de...
De musique, là
Bon
Est-ce qu'il faut que je filme ?
Ouais
"Don't be afraid you're going to Heaven"
Ne sois pas
N'aie pas peur
Tu vas aller au Paradis
Wow [Ok, c'est quoi ce bordel...]
[Est-ce que je perd la tête ?]
Euh, un peu
[Aller au ciel ...]
[Oh, mon Dieu. Avant qu'ils tuent les enfants.]
[Tu aurais dû m'aimer.]
[Je ...]
[Nan mais qu'est-ce que je fais ?]
Put*in mais, mec
Ça me met le bad ces vidéos, là
Ça me met vraiment le bad
Bon
En tout cas j'vais pas oublier de les faire
Dans cet épisode
Vous pouvez compter sur moi
J'vais...
Essayer de filmer tout ce qui bouge
Alors, du coup on va où ?
Parce que c'est bien beau, euh...
Cette, euh...
Cet endroit, euh...
Malsain
Ah bah là, hein, j'pense
Ouais, y a des escaliers qui montent
Fonçons, fonçons
Dès qu'il y a de la lumière
J'ai l'impression que c'est des mecs
Qui tiennent des lampes torches
Ça m'effraie, mon gars
C'est terrible
J'ai jamais autant dit dans une vidéo
Que je- que j'étais effrayé, mais
C'est considérable
Ah ! Une note, attention !
Encore un truc de fou
OBJECTIF : les enfants ne doivent pas craindre leur devoir, mais le célébrer comme un accès garanti au paradis.
D'accord
SOUVENEZ-VOUS : Il n'y a pas de douleur au paradis. Papa vous a donner les vie, et votre vie lui appartient.
*rire nerveux et pleures*
Ok, vas-y
J'ai même pas envie de lire la suite, mec
C'est, c'est du délire
C'est du délire ces proverbes
Allez, par la fenêtre
Euh, ou pas en fait
Si ?
Oh, m*rde
Oh, m*rde. Ouais mais j'avais pas le choix pour sortir
Alors p'tit bandage et on est bien
Voilà, en mode Far Cry.
On est bien,
Y a plus de blessures, plus de blessures qui tiennent.
Alors par où dois-je aller ?
Je peux filmer ça ? Nan, c'est bon ?
Euuuh, par là...
Ah, y a une note encore ?
A quoi servent ces notes? Je me demande, hein.
Maman, Madame Carson a dit que je peux pas te dire ce qu'ils vont faire, mais elle a pas dit que je pouvais pas écrire. Je t'en pris, ne les laissent pas me tuer. Je t'aime et j'aime papa. Juliana
Puta***n...
Mais mec, c'est horrible ce qu'ils ont fait,
Ils ont tuer des enfants, des puta*n d'enfants.
[Comment je peux atteindre cet endroit ?]
[Oh puta*in de clôture...]
[Je pourrais la grimper]
[Il me suffit de monter sur quelque chose.]
Ok
Je vais te trouver eu... ça.
Ça là, ça, ça, ça.
On va pousser ça.
Ca c'est une bonne idée ou pas ?
Est-ce qu'on a eu une bonne idée ?
Mais bien sûr, regardez, quelle bonne idée !
Vous pouvez regarder derrière vous lorsque vous poussez un objet en maintenant GAUCHE
[Prie avec moi.]
D'accord, je sais pas pourquoi vous précisez ça mais me...
m'indique rien de bon.
Ah mais y a une meuf, là, juste là en fait.
Avec sa... qui nous a one-shot dans le...
Ho puta***n ...
Ho, on est pas bien du tout là mec en vrai
On est pas bien du tout...
Et là c'est fermé, on va passer par la gauche directe
Aller vas-y, c'est parti
On y va, on y croit
Si ça se trouve c'est pas du tout par là.
Peut-être... Peut-être je suis entrain de faire euuu... la bêtises de ma vie.
Je ne sais point.
Attend, interagir. Je pouvais interagir.
Nan, je pouvais pas interagir. Nan, je pouvais juste me cacher, d'accord
C'est pas la même chose.
Enfin c'est une-
Ho, naaannn...
Naaaannn !
Par où c'est puta*n. Je sais pas par où aller c'est immense.
Mais où veux-tu que j'aille à la fin ?
On va par là hein.
Je tente hein, mec, je sais pas où faut aller.
Je suis totalement perdu dans mes pensées.
Autant que dans le jeu.
Sauvergarde.
Ah, c'était pas là.
Ho la p*te.
*bruit de sirène*
Eh ça marche vite ces sal*peries !
Donc faut aller de là où elle vient à mon avis, déjà.
*sirène et halètement*
Heuuu...
Ça va faire mal quand elle va me toucher.
*sirène*
Faut aller où bordel !
Avec sa pioche là.
Mais va miner du cuivre et laisse moi puta*n.
Faut pas aller là ?
Puta*n mais m*rde !
J'me cache, je me cache, je suis pas là, tu m'as pas vu.
*rire*
[Aaahhhh !!!]
Euuu, je sais pas où faut aller.
Ça a sauvegardé vers là, peut-être par là.
Ok, je l'ai semée, j'lai semée j'lai semée on est bien, j'lai semée.
Je sais pas comment j'ai fait mais j'lai semée mec.
J'ai fait un tour de pâté de maison elle en pouvais plus.
Je regarde derrière moi...
puis je regarde-
C'est bon elle arrive pas, elle arrive pas. On est bien (x3).
On a le temps (x2), on est large.
Puta*n c'est looiinnn de la porte !
Ho! Damn it !
Ah c'est bon elle c'est barrée, ho on a de la chance mon gars !
Aller salut, je me tire à bientôt.
Oh la la la la la la, quelle histoire !
mais quelle histoire !
Oh la la la la ...
Je suis désolé pour vous les mec. Ça fait un paquet d'années que vous êtes morts à mon avis.
Bon moi j'ai ma femme à trouver, Lynn !
Lynn (x5)
Est-ce que je peux entrer et choper des piles ? Ah peut-être tient.
Peut-être..
peut-être y a-t-il une pile ?
dans cet endroit. Parce que là je vais commencer à manquer de pile mine de rien.
Y a des poupées puta*n.
*rire stressé*
J'en peut plus. Avec des croix inversées bien évidemment.
Aaah... Une pile.
Ok
Puta*n, je- je- je fais bien de lire vos commentaires et de vous écouter, regardez :
Grâce à vous des piles...
J'apprend des trucs en plus que j'avais pas vu ...
Ooooh ....
C'est horrible.
Ho !
Elle est là !
La chapelle !
[La chapelle, une chapelle est censée être un sanctuaire...]
D'accord
Ce qui veut dire que c'est pas un sanctuaire là-bas.
Ouuaaa....
Aller on monte !
Ouuaaa, c'est imposant.
Alors,
une chapelle est censée être un sanctuaire...
Je me demande ce qu'on va découvrir en ouvrant cette porte mec, mais ...
Aba...
Pour le prophète révérend Sullivan Knoth de la part de Laird Byron, attesté par ...
Y a un mec ici, hein ?
Y a un- un gardien
Nan mais c'est sûr
Je dis pas ça pour vous effrayer
Mais...
C'est plus pour vous ...
[Mary ?]
[Knoth ?]
[Qui est là ? Qui êtes-vous ???]
[Je m'appelle Blake.]
[Etranger ...]
[Le père-]
[Je suis le père de personne ! J'ai juste ...]
[Tuez moi.]
[Vous devez me tuer.]
Mais nan, mais nan. [Knoth revient.]
[Avec Mary.]
[Il lui fera du mal et je dirais tout.]
[Si vous me tuez.]
[Il n'aura aucune raison de lui faire du mal.]
[Je vous en prie !]
*cris de femme au loin*
Euuh, mec euuh...
Je suis, je suis- je sais pas quoi. ça v-
Il y a des cris.
M*rde ! P'tain ça venais de derrière.
Il y a des cris de là-bas.
On va juste voir si y a pas... Ah, c'est pour se cacher.
Rhoo puta*n on se cache là-dedans quoi.
Ah sauvegarde !?
Tu veux dire qu'il fallait se cacher ? *bruit de porte*
*pleures* [Nous l'avons trouvée Josiah.]
[Elle essayait de s'enfuir parmi les galeux.]
[Ce ne sont pas là les actions d'une femme à la conscience immaculée.]
[Mary ??...]
[Oh mon Dieu ..A non ! ...] *pleures*
[Réponds à ton compagnon ma chère, il ne te voit pas.]
[Faites la répondre !]
[C'est moi Josiah.]
[S'il-te-plait dis leur que je l'ai pas.]
aannhhh !... Il est horrible....
*pleures du couple*
[Dieu hait la vanité.]
[Moi aussi ! ]
[La femme étrangère cache la destruction de ce monde en son ventre.]
[Mais Val et ses apostats on volé l'ennemie à naître.]
[Le père du démon s'est échappé ! ]
[Son immonde récolte sera moissonnée avant l'aube.]
[Nous disposons seulement de quelques heures pour la retrouver et la tuer.]
[Et ainsi sauver ce paradis de l'enfer éternel.]
[Où est-elle ?]
[Où Val l'a-t-il emmenée ??!!!]
[Je ne peux pas. Je ne peux pas.]
[C'est pour toi Josiah...]
[Faites la crier !!!]
[Non]
[Naaannn]
[Nan]
[Où est la femme ?]
[Le ventre qui habite l'antéchrist !]
[Non] *cris de douleur*
[Non]
[Force de l'ange rebelle. Pour l'enfant à naître je n'ai aucune peur.]
[Force de l'ange rebelle. Je n'ai aucune peur.]
[Force ennemie de mon ennemie, ennemie de mon ennemie, ennemie de mon enn- ]
[Dites à Josiah d'arrêter, Dieu n'entend pas les putains pécheresses.]
*pleures de la femme et bruit strident*
Oh puta*n il va se faire démolir.
[Où est la femme ?]
[Où Val l'a-t-il emmenée !!!!?]
*cris de l'homme et son de plus en plus strident*
[Arrêtez, arrêtez !...]
[Je vais parler !]
[Je vais...Tout dire...]
[Mon Dieu]
[Je suis désolé Mary, je suis désolé.]
[Où est la femme !!!!]
[Les mines, dans la montagne.]
[Val l'a emmenée dans les mines.]
Naannn ... [Vous ne la retrouverez jamais !]
[Pas avant la naissance ...] Naannn ...
[Nous sommes les mains du seigneur]
[Nous ne pouvons pas échouer.]
Donc Lynn est dans les mines, dans les montagnes.
[Ce monde meurt en criant.]
[Ton Dieu dans toute ton arrogance sera- ]
[Laissez la se reposer.]
*bruit de la machine de torture et cris d'agonie*
D'accord
*bruit de la machine de torture et cris d'agonie qui cessent*
Très bien !
Il faut qu'on aille dans les mines avant eux.
Bon on va pouvoir y aller.
[M*rde, ces fils de p*te !]
[Les mines. Où sont ces puta*n de mines ?]
Ouais, il faut qu'on aille au mines mec.
Bon tant pis je filme lui apparemment y a une séquence à faire ...
Ho mais mec !!! C'est d'une violence, faut aller dans les mines là vite !
[Ils font toujours ...
du mal aux femmes pour punir les hommes.]
[C'est malade...
lâche.]
Heu, je te fais pas dire mon gars.
Aller on sort, il faut qu'on aille dans les mines. Comment on va dans les mines ?
Faut repartir par là ?
Elle est, elle est ...
Ah, ok, nickel ! Parfait. D'accord, elle est vraiment, euu, sur un truc de torture.
Faut que je me casse. Alors là mec, on va essayer, de se concentrer.
[Il était dans la chapelle]
Ouais, il était la chapelle et il n'y retournera pas
Puta*n, ils me courent après de ouf.
[Il se dirige vers le pont.]
Donc, je pense que c'est par là, à mon avis c'est à gauche ici, là.
Ah non ça !
Raa, ok c'est bon ça l'a fait mec. J'ai tellement eu peur de me faire choper.
On sort la cam' , par là.
On monte les marches.
Allez go go go go go
Ils me suivent encore là ?
Nan c'est bon- Ah, si il arrivent puta*n je les ai vus.
Ho les b*tards ils sont en bas ...
Aller, yes ! C'est pas le moment de glisser mec.
Ok on est bien
Ils sont où ces m*rdeux ? Ils sont toujours là ?
Ah ils sont là puta*n, "téma" le.
Ah il est plus là, on le voit plus.
Ah puta*n !
Ho la pression... Donne moi la pile !
Je sais pas ce que je suis censé foutre une fois qu- à bha aller par là.
Ho mec !... On saute ça, et il est temps d'avancer mon gars, puta*n !
Alors, par où on doit aller une fois qu'on est là ?
On a une pile. Ça, c'est -
Ouais faut, faut dire ce qui est bien : on a eu une pile, on- on est bien.
On est mieux que si on avait pas eu de pile.
Et ça me permettra d'utiliser souvent la caméra pour que vous voyez quelque chose, hein
Vous savez que lorsque vous voyez rien sur Youtube lorsque je met pas la caméra, moi non plus je vois rien.
Genre là.
Même moi je vois quasi rien.
C'est hyper sombre mec.
[Ne pleure pas.] ♫
*berceuse morbide*
[Rendors toi.] ♫
[Mon petit enfant.] ♫
[Souffre enfant.] ♫
[Jour et nuit.] ♫ Est-ce, est-ce qu- est-ce que je passe derrière elle ?
[Un jour tu te réveillera au ciel.] ♫
Elle a pas l'air méchant, hein. C'est ses enfants juste qui on été tué quoi.
Donc elle est traumatisée.
[Noir et pâle.] ♫    Après je dis pas que je resterais là à t'écouter à vie quand même mais ...
Mais t'as pas l'air méchante, j'esp-
j'espère vraiment que la prochaine fois que je te verrais t'aura- ...
[Qui à l'arrière ?!]
[Hey, toi .....]
Prend ça en photo.
Aller !
Puta*n... [Il est où ?] Puta*n.
Faut que je m'échappe par la fenêtre dans les champs ?
Aller vas-y go !
Ok, là je vois rien !
Typiquement je vois rien,
mais typiquement il va falloir qu'on
fasse quelque chose.
aannhh ... C'est le tout début du jeu en fait là ?
Vous vous souvenez de ce mec ?
C'est le tout début du puta*n de jeu mec !
Rolalalala, c'est une catastrophe de se retrouver là.
Ça brise le morale ça. Je rampe mais au moins je serais pas repérer.
Au moins, moi et mes abonnés on fera pas un arrêt cardiaque...
Damn it !
Lui il est pas loin lui ...
Pour moi faut traverser hein.
Pour moi y a pas d'autres solutions, faut juste traverser, faut aller au bout.
Y a pas, pas d'autre choix là, pas d'autre possibilité
Faut traverse ce champs...
Attend, je vais m'accroupir pour aller plus vite.
Woaw, ok.
On parle de machettes de qualité, hein.
On parle de machettes de qualité.
On va pas se mytho.
Woaaa... Il est tellement proche ce b*tard.
Je recule hein.
A mon avis, il faut escalader la palissade que y a là pour accéder au champs de l'autre côté, qui lui donnera ...
Il viens vers nous là ?
Hoooo....
Scandaleux,
Scandaleux !
Ok, maintenant faut y aller.
On a faillit se faire cramer...
On s'est fait cramer ! On s'est fait cramer !
Tu m'auras jamais !
Il nous coure après !
Huaa !
..... la Fureur de l’Éternel !]
[Il doit y avoir un moyen d'arrêter la roue]
[Mes yeux fous sont comme deu- ]
Par là, par là !
[ -gouffres indignes !]
HO puta*nn !!! Il nous colle au c*l !
C'est quoi ça ?
NAN ! Faut trouver une manivelle.
YOLO !
Ho je suis mort...
Y a une manivelle a trouvé mec, c'est  le pire truc qui pouvait nous arriver,
y a pas pire, y a pas à pire, réellement !
Elle est là !!!
Ho, j'ai la manivelle !
Attend, faudrait que je me soigne, faut que je me soigne.
H bandage, H, je me trompe de touche
Soigne toi,
et au moins on sait où faut le mettre. Mec j'ai eu tellement de chance
Aller on y va mec. S'il est là c'est un vieux gars.
Ok, c'est un vieux gars.
Ah.
Ah ouais.... Aller la manivelle.
Et maintenant ?
Aller tourne, tourne la manivelle, tourne la manivelle.
Comment j'y vais ? Comment j'y vais ? Comme ça ?
Bon bha à mon avis c'est là, faut aller là, voilà c'est bon, j'ai trouvée voilà, exactement comme ça aller, on s'enfuit!!!
Laisse-nous, laisse-nous, laisse-nous, laisse-nous, laisse-nous le truc, c'est qu'il rampe maintenant c'est
bat*rd!!
par là
on est bien
en bas, ok....
une vache morte à droite c'est ça?
Nickel, super....
Ah yes, ils viennent pas, les mecs se découragent, ça fait très plaisir!!!!
puta*n... une pile!!
Elle est à moi, elle m'appartient, c'est ma pile!!!
Faut que j'aille où?!
Bon bas on vas suivre les herbes mec, on vas pas se mentir...
ok, ça nous redirige puta*n mais ces animaux morts partout mec, j'en peux plus!!!
y'a une maison, est-ce que c'est l-...
What....... puta*n....
c'est par la qu'il faut aller, il y a un trou ouais c'est par la à mon avis....
alors, qu'elle est cette maison, une note!!!
on les prends toutes les notes mec!!!
Oh yes, une pile ah, ça veut dire que c'est un truc à *****, vous pensez que là où on trouve les piles
en vrai c'est juste un endroit à *****, il faut pas y aller?
Bas, on à bien fait mec, on a gagner une pile en deux deux,
on s'est mis bien!!
si c'est pas là, c'est tous droit!!!
puta*n de me*de....
Ah, je me fraye un chemin!!
Oh lalalala, faut aussi arrêter le délire avec les mannequins, faut arrêter à tous prix, hein!! Ah, bandages!!!
Puta*n puta*n, on en avait utiliser,
ça va nous faire du bien!!!
On est où là, dans une ferme...
enfin une ferme, dans ce qu'il reste d'une ferme!!!
Ohhhh,
ouais...
et qu'es ce qu'il me faut?!
Faut un crochet....
où je peux trouver ça mec?
Bon mec à mon avis le crochet est pas là , ce serait beaucoup trop simple!!!
Donc on vas ce bouger!!
J'peux pas l'ouvrir mieux que ça, non c'est fait exprès puta*n si je me fais poursuivre ça va être horrible...
la maison à droite on a déjà faite...
c'est pareil, il reste que ça de toute façon!!
c'est forcément par là!!!
Me dis pas qu'avec son flair elle me sent et elle va venir là *rires*, pitié, va t'en!!!
puta*n mais grave mec!!!
Vas t'en, va t'en, viens pas vers moi, viens pas vers moi, va t'en,
va bien loin, bien bien loin!!!
Oh, elle m'a vu puta*n, comment elle à fais, je sais pas, I don't no!!!
ok, on est sauvé, on est sauvé...
par là, ok, c'est bon...
oh puta*n!!! Oh le p'tit tour qui nous à mis bien!!!
On arrive où là?
Oh... je suis désolé mec...
j'suis désolé meuf...
je suis désolé heu.... je sais même plus ce que...
qu'elle sexe tu étais... c'est terrible!!!
Es- ce qu'on à un crochet éventuellement??? Oh bas là, on à de beaux crochets!!!
On a décroché le beau crochet si je peux  me
permettre!!!!
Ah, je pourrais sortir par là, c'est pas une mauvais idée, ça!!!
En attendant, il faut que j'aille heu... dedans...
c'est dégelasse bon, est-ce que au final je peux quand même prendre un crochet?
Je mérite bien un crochet après avoir vu tous ça en vrai, non mais en vrai!!!
Il y en à un, c'est sûr..
y'a bien un crochet pour Lucas....
#UncrochetpourLucassvp...
ah il est là regarder, là haut!!!
On a un crochet!!!
Y'a plus qu'à retourner à l'autre endroit et on est bon, je sais même plus où c'est mec!!!
Heu.....
faut que je me casse là en vrai!!!
J'me casse très loin!!
J'vais me casser très très très loin!!
c'est par où que j'étais passer??
C'étais ici, c'étais là...
bon bas va falloir que je joue à cache-cache maintenant, faut pas se mentir...
je ne sais pas
où est cette
puta*n de dame!!!
Bon mec à un moment, on y vas...
faut y aller franco comme James...
mec, tu vas avoir une seconde pour faire ton délire avec ton crochet, j'sais pas c'que ta comme idée
en tête mais fais-le, do it!!!
Et bas non, oh la chaîne est juste là, j'suis trop c*n mec, oh mais là c'est trop tard déjà!!!
c'est pire mais, je déteste ça, voilà!!!!
Aller au revoir, on en parle plus!!
Oh......
ouais....
dans le prochaine épisode ouais!!!
A bientôt pour l'épisode 4, merci d'avoir regardé, au revoir les amis!!!
Merci d'avoir lu les sous-titres,  nous espérons que ça vous à plus, dites ce que vous pensez de notre travail dans les commentaires et si quelque chose vous déplait, nous l'améliorons!!